كانوا يحفرون بأيديهم بين
الغبار وأنقاض ما كان ذات يوم منزلاً،
وبحثوا عن ناجين من
أعنف زلزال شهده المغرب منذ
عقود
بعد وقت قصير من الساعة 11 مساءً يوم الجمعة، كان هناك
زلزال قصير ثم اهتزت الأرض
وبدأت المباني في الانهيار.
سمع الناس يصرخون، خرج الجميع
من منازلهم، يتذكر محمد
تكفي، الشارع مليء بالناس
والنساء يصرخون، هذا ما حدث
حتى الآن لا يستطيع الناس العودة إلى منازلهم
لأنهم ما زالوا خائفين من الفوضى
والارتباك الذي تفاقم بسبب
الهزات الارتدادية المتكررة
للعديد من الناس  ناموا إذا استطاعوا النوم على
الإطلاق في الساحات العامة والحدائق ومن
بينهم السياح الذين
انتهت إجازاتهم الهم فجأة بدأت الغرفة تهتز
هناك فقط نعم بدأت الغرفة
تهتز ليس هناك طريقة أخرى كنا
نسير إلى الخلف والأمام وبدأ
كل شيء يتحرك وبدأت الصور
تحركنا وخرجنا بسرعة بحلول منتصف
بعد ظهر يوم السبت، تجاوز عدد القتلى
1000 شخص وكان من المتوقع أن يرتفع
بينما غمرت المستشفيات
مئات الجرحى منهم في حالة حرجة
على الأقل لم يكن هناك نقص في الأشخاص الذين
يصطفون في طوابير للتبرع بالدم،
وكان مركز الزلزال  في جبال الأطلس الكبير الوعرة، على بعد
45 ميلاً جنوب غرب
مراكش، مما يعقد جهود
فرق الإنقاذ التي تحاول الوصول إلى
البلدات والقرى النائية.
المساعدة من الخارج في طريقها من
فرنسا والإمارات العربية المتحدة وتركيا
وإسرائيل وأماكن أخرى، ولا يمكن أن
تصل المساعدة قريبًا بما فيه الكفاية.